[Music]
hey friends Drex here from Drex Factor
po sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today we're going to
take a look at one of the wildest parts
of the tech po movement of the late
2000s that is the atomic weave but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Tera light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the non-
business Friends of the channel L
machinski and Becca beckin thank you
both so much for supporting my Channel
my work and my mission so Atomic weaves
are part of what was kind of a weird
little tangent of the tech po world in
the late 2000s and the early 2010s
basically you got a lot of people that
decided that they were going to take all
these things that they had been learning
in wall plane and wheel plane and trying
to see what would happen if they
operated under the assumption that the
two po didn't have to be in the same
plane at the same time this actually is
not as strange an idea as it might sound
as it turns out a lot of things that we
do with POI work in multiple different
planes and when you put them together
they surprisingly still hold together
too now it does need to be said that
there are multiple poy tricks that count
as atomic weaves for instance this right
here was the first atomic weave that I
ever encountered uh my friend Christian
actually showed me this one way back in
I want to say it was November of
2007 it was also the first P trick I saw
that ever broke my brain and if you look
carefully at it you'll see that it's
just a variation on a buzzsaw weave if
you want something that is more
traditional we also have this variation
on an atomic weave right here which
depending upon the angle that you view
it at either looks like it is in Split
time opposites or split Time same
direction however the atomic weave that
I want to focus on is this number right
here the one that involves combining
together a vertical plane and a
horizontal plane why is that the
variation I want to focus on well mainly
because I think it just produces the
most interesting results and certainly
the easiest ones to teach but also
because I've been on kind of a toid kick
lately and I have to say that having the
plane presented on angle to the audience
and working with a vertical and a
horizontal is something that I'm just
really digging right now if you'd like
to see tutorials on any of the other
variations leave me a comment and let me
know and maybe I'll do a followup so the
first thing we need to understand here
is that each hand is responsible for for
one single plane orientation but
otherwise the movement of it is
identical to what we would find in a
normal 3B weave I'm going to have my
left hand performing a 3B weave in a
vertical wheel plane orientation so it's
going to perform two beats over on my
right side and one beat over on my left
side you'll note this also makes it work
in such a way that you always see the
plane on end from the perspective of the
audience now my right hand is going to
be hanging out in horizontal kind of
place and it's going to be tempting to
have it work in something that feels
roughly like a cork screw doing a beat
over and a Beat under and there is
actually a way to do an atomic weave
like this but it feels very lopsided to
me instead what I want you to do is go
ahead and perform one two beats on top
and one beat on the bottom one two beats
up top and one beat on the bottom if
this feels a little strange and lopsided
it is because when we get into a
horizontal plane we're dealing with an
orientation where doing a TW beat weave
feels more symmetrical as opposed to
when we're working in vertical planes
where three beats feels more symmetrical
it's just kind of baked into that all
right so the next step is we're just
going to perform a normal 3B weave first
here in wheel plane this should feel
very familiar and comfortable if you
don't already know how to do a 3B weave
I'll go ahead and include a link to a
tutorial on how to do that down in the
description as well as up here in the
cards if you're watching on YouTube get
in 10 reps like this cuz the next step
is things are going to get kind of weird
all right so our next step here is that
you're actually going to take your upper
body and you're going to tilt it just
slightly over to your right and from
this orientation I want you to try and
perform a 3B weave that is even with the
angle that your upper body is keeled
over at hopefully something like a 45
degree angle here now you're going to
find that you're going to have to fight
a little bit to get both of the poy over
to your left- hand side because they're
also working against gravity and they're
going to have an easier time sinking
down to the right side because they're
working with gravity and that's exactly
what this should feel like again see if
you can get in 10 reps like this
adjusting the angle of the planes in
order to match the angle of your upper
body all right so next we're going to go
ahead and move our perspective
completely over to the side this is
going to feel a little uncomfortable but
we don't need to stay here for too
terribly long again I want you to try
and see if you can get in a 3B weave
where with your perspective turned
completely over to the side and now it's
going to start to feel a lot like a cork
screw but a kind of odd cork screw
because you're doing two beats with one
hand on top and two beats with the other
hand on bottom but other than that you
should still have some knowledge here in
terms of how the 3 beat weave should
feel as you're going back and forth here
all right so we're going to start to put
together the pieces incrementally here I
want you to go ahead and perform your
vertical 3B weave here in wheel plane
once again and I want you to notice this
point where the right hand is going
underneath the left hand you get a
little upbeat by the right hand poy
there if I show you this from the side
it happens right there something
different is going to happen here namely
as that right hand poy is going under
rather than poking the POI up you're
going to pull it across you're going to
do a little kind of move over to the
right hand side it's going to sweep past
your Bas As you move both hands over to
the left so it changes from this to this
and then you can take it right back to a
vertical place so think it veers right
it veers right it veers right as you go
back and forth between these two
locations all right so the next step is
we're going to add more horizontal
movement over here on the right hand
side so we've already got the right hand
kind of veering over and then switching
back into a vertical plane over here on
the right right hand side What If
instead of doing that popping up in the
vertical plane we instead let the right
hand Poise sweep underneath both hands
let me show you so we Veer over we sweep
under we Veer over we sweep under Veer
over sweep under Veer over sweep under
once we've done this it's going to feel
pretty natural to keep the poy in a
horizontal plane even when it moves over
the leftand poy so the thing to bear in
mind as we're doing this is is that the
right hand is actually still performing
the function of a 3B weave it just
happens to be doing it in a horizontal
plane as it turns out we can just decide
that we're going to Boom flip one of the
planes over and the movements underlying
the 3B weave still fundamentally work
when you start to get this down one of
my favorite things to do with it is
actually to make it travel just a little
bit you can make the PO go over and
under your hands as you move them around
in space and basically turn this into
almost like a box pattern that you're
tracing out as you go around pretty cool
huh if you're finding that that right
hand plane is going off on more of a
diagonal than a horizontal hey you're
not the only one who's been there I've
had that problem too here's how you can
start to correct for it the first thing
to realize is that this is going to take
more articulation from your right wrist
than you're used to where your left hand
really doesn't have that much work to do
your right hand now has to trace out a
much more smooth path in order to make
these horizontal planes work here's what
to watch out for number one when you get
to that point over on your right hand
side when the right hand PO is
underneath your hand you really want to
make sure that your fingers are pointing
down towards the floor you can always
think of the plane that the PO is moving
in as being like a wheel and your thumb
and forefinger especially if you're
using the key grip like I'm using here
is kind of like the axle of that wheel
so whichever direction those two fingers
are pointing in that is the direction
perpendicularly that the plane is going
to wind up in so really think that
you're pointing your thumb and
forefinger down and your thumb and your
forefinger up as you're moving back and
forth that is going to help clarify
those planes and really really really
help to make this look beautiful there
is also one other variation that
involves kind of reaching the right hand
over around underneath the left wrist
like this a lot of people like this
myself included because it kind of
balances out the movement of the right
hand now that we're moving in horizontal
Al planes it helps to add that extra
beat on bottom to make this Quirk screw
like motion feel just a little bit more
balanced out because again when we're
working in horizontal planes things that
have even beats feel even whereas when
we're working in vertical planes things
that have odd beats feel more even so it
is an option here um I have mixed
feelings about it myself but you can
definitely play around with it if you'd
like to cool so there you go let me
leave you with a little bit of POV
footage so you can see what this looks
like from where you are
[Music]
[Applause]
also if you dig the POI I was using in
this video and why wouldn't you because
they are absolutely gorgeous these are
fabric sock poy made by a company called
sock poy that was started by poy
educator Kia stockan NOA you can get a
pair for yourself over at soo. store and
if you use the promo code Drex Factor
you can get 5% off your order plus which
it helps out the channel so go add some
socks to your life and find the joy in
them yeah did you get anything out of
this video please make sure to like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible were it
not for the kind support of all of these
awesome people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
even better they voted to make this
video one that I would produce so you
owe them a debt of thanks as do I if you
out there watching are not currently
suppor but would like to become one you
can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor pooy and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards but even better
than that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if you
would like to check out some of my other
videos on 3D poy Concepts including
things like plane breaking and toids I
will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you're watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here based
upon your past viewing habits so maybe
give that a look as well thanks so much
for watching make sure to get out and
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon peace